I'm gonna have a last day in city's ty
it's gonna be with you Oh Troy and
Gabriella we know you guys are out there
somewhere going strong you are literally
made for each other it didn't matter
that you belong to two very different
worlds you managed to make it work
we're sure you heard about the High
School Musical reboot and we're sure
you're just as excited about it as we
are after all the teams at East High
will be acting out your love story isn't
that amazing Ricky and Mimi are the
modern-day Troy and Gabriella but do
they have what it takes to make it to
the finish line
here's everything you need to know about
the High School Musical reivew watch
until the end to find out why Nene Ricky
and EJ's love triangle is unlike any
we've ever seen before
the series is being filmed at East High
with Disney's new streaming platform
right around the corner the house of
mouse is letting viewers in on their
upcoming projects and high school
musical the musical the series is one
that catches the eye of many Millennials
if you watch the original trilogy who
might be pleased to know that the series
is being filmed at the exact same high
school
the musical dramedy will be shot
documentary style since the students
will be putting on a theater version of
Troy and Gabriella slub story this is
Disney's way of tying both franchises
together and we can't wait to see the
final product the series will have ten
episode most busy Channel shows don't
run for longer than three to four
seasons but when it comes to the High
School Musical reboot the series will
have a total of ten episodes much like
the original movies the reboot will be
jam-packed with songs that revolve
around unity friendship and heartache
the reboot is set to debut on Disney
Plus on November 12 2019 then watching
the entire series will be easy to do
with only 10 short episodes stars in the
making Disney wanted to cast fresh faces
into their production which is why they
chose actors of different calibers actor
Joshua Bassett who plays Ricky appeared
in nine episodes of stuck in the middle
before landing the leading
role in the hsm reboot playing his
ex-girlfriend Nene is actress Olivia
Rodrigo you might recognize her as Paige
ol Vera from Buzard bark and then
there's actor Matt Cornett who plays EJ
together Nene Ricki and EJ make up a
super complicated love triangle the plot
the series will revolve around Ricki
Mimi and EJ's love triangle thanks to
the trailer we now know that Ricky and
Nene used to date and they were perfect
together until Ricky asked to press
pause on their relationship Ricky
instantly regrets his decision when he
finds out that Nene is now dating a jock
named EJ to win Nene back Ricky
auditions for the high school musical
Nene gets cast at Gabriella and Ricky
gets cast destroyed with the musical
quickly approaching
Nene struggles with her emotions making
for a very complicated love story keep
watching to find out why you might end
up shipping EJ and Nene
instead of Nene and Ricky the eccentric
miss Chen who could forget about the
strict and passionate theatre teacher
miss darbus from the original HSN
franchise despite being a kind-hearted
woman she did have her quarks miss
darbus was played by actress Alison Reed
but the Disney Channel has chosen to go
in a different direction for the reboot
actors Cate rynders is set to play Miss
Jen and she's more than a little
eccentric this enthusiastic teacher is
bound to give East tides of pep it
deserves and she definitely played a
hand in casting Ricky and ninny as Troy
and Gabriella the Gina problem move over
Sharpay East High has a new entitled
princess and her name is Gina Gina and
Nene don't get along throughout the
series in fact they're pretty much
rivals to her great surprise Gina gets
cast as the understudy instead of the
lead so she plans to mess with ninnies
confidence to get her to step down as
the musicals leading woman Gina
isn't someone to mess with just look how
angry she looked when minion
that she was auditioning for the role of
Gabriela Carlos the choreographer when
watching the trailer it's easy to
mistake Carlos as the new Sharpay but
that couldn't be farther from the truth
this brand new character is the musical
choreographer and he's super talented
Carlos and Miss Jen are super close and
love working together after Frankie
Rodriguez brings sass and charisma to
his character in true Sharpay fashions
but in the end he's not interested in
being the star of the show the new Kelsi
every musical needs a composer and since
Kelsey graduated a long time ago a new
one had to be picked
say hello to Ashlyn the new kid at East
High she's a songwriter and also happens
to be EJ's cousin we see Ashlyn and Mimi
sitting at a piano together in the
trailer so she's definitely the new
Kelsey however Ashlyn is going to be a
lot more outgoing than Kelsey was the
truth about EJ we all ship Troy and
Gabriella but the high school musical
reboot has the potential to change our
OTP as it turns out EJ isn't a bad guy
Disney refers to him as an ambitious
entrepreneur so while he might come off
as a jock in the trailer there's a lot
more to EJ than meets the eye
EJ is a confident guy who secretly has
panic attacks
he loves Nene and doesn't want to lose
her once you get to know each a you
might find yourself shipping Nene and EJ
over Nene and Ricky who do you think
will be your favorite new character tell
us in the comments and thanks for
watching
for more fun content press that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time on the theme
[Music]